yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is a bit different to the more
frequently posted tea session set up tea
sessions Wow
this is about me trying to solve some
chess problems and puzzles we had the
puzzles it sure thanks against to Willam
for the nice pictures
um so I'm going to try to solve a couple
of more difficult exercise exercises and
there are many good books to provide
with high level exercise for this video
I went form our gods that's not
completely right grandmaster preparation
positional play and he's got 150
exercises at the end of the book they
even more with this just one 150
position a block that is not
I'm attached to a certain subject so
sometimes you get hints what to look for
if the subject instead say prophylaxis
you need to you look you you will look
more for the opponent's possibilities
than if the subject would be completely
unknown so there are 150 positions and
I'm just going to randomly select some
of them and it might happen that I know
the position because I used some of them
for my own lessons so I might have to
roll the dice more than once
or let's see what see 145 so let's see
if I know this position or not
nope I don't know the position okay so
let's go for this is a game Michnik ends
together and we are looking at this from
the from the black side and of course I
have couldn't prepare the positions
because they are remnant be selected so
yelets
with position on the board
it takes a moment but I don't think it's
avoidable really if you do it do it like
that
yeah I guess I could
you the dice rolling
forehand but
I know that people will then post 'are
you cheated or something i know i know
how it works
though this one
still need some rooks
and on g1 so this is the position it
seems it's black to move
this right okay
I'm sorry I'm I'm really bad at setting
up positions I tend to screw little
details up and today often do count okay
I'm going to switch the board and check
this from blacks perspective of course I
don't use an engine that would be here
rather pointless so ya like to move
first of all we need to look at this
position a little bit and try to figure
out what's going on it is equal material
this position is probably
as probably
arisen from the queen's indian queen a
four line against a quasi three bishop a
six cuneiform so it's an interesting
struggle strategically speaking white
currently has some pressure against the
pawn but this pawn is safely protected
so we're not going to lose it anytime
soon
but there are some other things going on
um one interesting point Yemm is that
Bishop takes e5 currently might be a
threat as there is so much pressure on
the D file
another idiom that we have to be aware
of as blackest night to be five may be
to increase the pressure and the typical
idea also important in this kind of
scenario is to move e5 that can also be
tricky because let's say it would be
white smooth and e5 happens now we might
have g4 then but it would be awkward
because we cannot take only five s d8 as
here under and the pressure and d5 also
wouldn't be possible so we need to deal
with a couple of a couple of ideas him
mm okay
an interesting fact is that we have g5
plate
that is sometimes allowing g4 I'm
pushing the night away from f3 that can
be an important resource and it is sort
of a candidate here as well even though
after g4 I'm going to put it on the
board I think it makes it easier for
people to follow the night only has h41
if we assume 91 here the problem would
be that h6 is hanging just attacked and
white still a threatening Bishop takes
e5 + e5 they don't quite see how I'm
address both ideas so I think g4 is
probably not correct at the moment
hmm so what's going on here
you
an interesting question is what happens
if I just develop I mean a normal way to
play would be to move the night of the
night it's not yet in clay and c6 or d7
Yahoo reasonable looking moves
the most normal one is I ibly knight c6
as this is looking at important squares
a question here is what happens after
five this is the thing if white coffee 5
do we have a good reply to that
and Hecht I think we can just take it
right can just take it
now that doesn't seem to be a problem
we have 97
what I don't like about 97 is that the
night is having no no active idea
if you go to c6 you at least can imagine
a scenario where black plays and I know
it might look awkward at first but
sometimes you can play something like e
five and then put the knight to d4 right
after all it has a weakness on the form
so knight c6 is so strategically
speaking more desirable move if we look
at this in terms of candidates what
other moves would be candidates it's not
that much I think as we're really
dealing with those ideas with Bishop
takes and and potentially five
ah
you
what I wonder about is if we go nights
is six again the movie five this is
something that I'm not completely sure
of what I'm doing now I don't think I
want to allow the capture on these six I
don't want to isolate this pawn so we
have to check out the captures and if we
take with the pawn this is looking a
little bit awkward
yeah let's say rook takes rook takes
[Music]
yeah this is actually not so clear I
mean this is I think a little bit better
for white as c5 is such a weak poner if
you got the serum it looks I mean maybe
it's more than a little bit better for
white the Stokes a bit awkward and the
bishop takes
yeah c5 is hanging but he also has this
and this is probably not a good idea
you
you know 93
[Music]
that doesn't even work yes I'm
like that is pretty embarrassing
of the night
it doesn't look all that great
and I do something else against you five
I can't eat with the night
five
then let's say we take here
this also
doesn't in doesn't look so great
so I don't think
getting the the point of this
you
an interesting idea that a hat is if you
play
87 simply focusing more on the
prophylactic side of things
then he 5 an idea that I immediately
thought off was Bishop f3 in this
position
going for an exchange sacrifice this
actually
is interesting that is not completely
outlandish to look at at least
but it is even that is not enough and
that is not enough just kingi to
no it doesn't look right
and the the second issue is that after
Bishop f3
and you also have to look at D takes it
takes D six also be a bit of an issue if
you look at this
rook has to move and I mean the
resulting position looks awful yeah I
don't quite believe in that
that's just dis just doesn't work
actually
so this also doesn't work okay
[Music]
you
so what do we do
what are we playing in this position
you
um I just had an idea
and the idea is the following G 491
Bishop g5 is said maybe an idea
you
it's kind of interesting
I guess white will take
and now the question is does he have
something
really convincing here because if I get
if I get to e5 with this night I'm
definitely okay
the night is super save on default of
course it also would be good the issue
must be e 5 in this position and that is
probably ending
ending the whole line is it
you can actually actually consider this
like this one and 96
just going for this big square x94
mm tougher that's a tough position
definitely interesting to him to think
about solving this kind of this kind of
puzzles it's not a classic puzzle and
that it has a super clear solution in a
technical way but this can really help
to improve your play just to think
deeply about such a position and yet try
to figure out what the key elements are
I wonder if I'm missing something in
those five lines when I play 96 or 97
maybe I miss a of evaluating them I have
no idea this is interesting though it's
also an active way to play
the move Knight h4 by the way is more or
less
I think refuted by Bishop g5
or take it that is trapping the night
and you don't want the double pawn or
the e-file so
probably has to play something that he
really doesn't want to play like rookie
1 or something so nighty 1 has to be
played here and we can check this a
little bit more maybe my initial
evaluation here that the pawn is hanging
and this is hanging was too shallow
anyway Bishop g5 is indeed interesting
as we have looked at but you can also
consider just to play Knight to c6 in
this position
if now Bishop age six the move 94 is
possible
you
it's not really covering this
before there's a night be three problem
mmm so this is an option Bishop g5 is an
option here off maybe knight c6 let's
have a look at this again so takes takes
e5 this must be the critical line
no I have to take it's not much
- what else to do maybe maybe
King takes instead of night takes
so let's do this 96
yeah II more or less has to take
otherwise yeah as to take
and now
94 again
you
maybe 94 is the problem here
i deform
you
yeah that looks like
the problem
you
yeah that that looks bad maybe this is
the issue
have anything else there so
this could be the problem that the king
takes on g2 in this line
you
mmm not really convinced right takes
takes
you
no I cannot quite get it to work
you
or is there anything else here we have
to always go back then and see if you
can improve
but yeah what else is they have to take
there's nothing else
so maybe Bishop g5 is not really doing
it
we had this knight c6 idea yeah and I
think if black manages to play h5 and
simply cover that pawn it's not an issue
really
so takes a 94 that that is interesting
that's definitely an interesting line
I'm not sure that I see a refutation
[Music]
the g4 point is a little bit on its own
here but not able to attack out
interesting I was just thinking that
I was just thinking that this is also
something that that could be checked
actually because if white takes and that
must be critical takes takes rook takes
Bishop takes rook takes knight c6 we
look at this all night ace let's go
knight c6 now I okay I see it doesn't
work but I was thinking that if we get
here that could be something but the
problem is that after 93 this is not you
cannot save it so this is a this is an a
nonsensical idea it doesn't work
my best bet is this line really and 94 I
don't feel like a soft that really
doesn't feel like a softer so I suggest
to look at the solution that it's it's a
long it's a long I looked at it for
quite quite some time and I couldn't
quite figure it out I think now it's
interesting to check what the solution
is
and they're curious
Aiki like maybe I screwed something up
with with those lines here 96 or 97
or night is six was right
yeah so this is what you want to play
but I did not see the key move after in
five this is the thing
yeah
and here the move I missed is Knight a5
going for the counter plane
yeah
it makes a lot of sense
the line Nicholas II takes night chicks
Bishop takes Knight b3 ship t69 txt to
yeah it seems that everything works here
Linna
not easy to figure figure this out for
sure but I didn't even look at 95 so
let's do one thing I'd like to go back
and switch on the engine and see um how
various lines fare so the engine
immediately gives the quoted variation
with 96 and basically says everything
else is terrible so again I felt like I
didn't get it right by the way
Vala in the game late 97 and that that
is a disaster yeah and this is what I
saw basically um but it's a bit it's a
bit odd that he still went for it
because this is quite clearly not right
this was help this happened in the game
just to see this is something that I
also saw and I didn't put on the board
this kind of ending yeah this is a
terrible ending
it's just a bad ending we looked at Tim
something very similar I guess
so I'm pretty awful yeah this is very
weekend you just have huge problems to
even yeah keep keep your things together
you're on the queenside
um and the here the exchange a sacrifice
whatever doesn't work due to IDI sex
which is there which was confirmed by
the engine so I looked at Knights is 65
I didn't see Knight a5 the key move I
looked at the other moves and I thought
they were bad again yeah I looked at
this this is actually exactly the line
that I just gave why a 97 which is bad
for luck as I concluded d takes e5 is
also not good I think I got that one
right yeah all those lines are bad
widest OS 1 + 1 here and this is a kind
of evaluation that goes up if you give
it more time yeah every little ply of
depth um will make blacks position look
more miserable and what I'm interested
in is the g4 move how terrible that
really is ok I completely missed that
Knight e5 is actually a move
okay
that's a huge problem also but 91 I just
wanted to check if this is making any
sense or not
yeah Bishop g5 I think didn't work due
to due to e5 and this is
supported by the engine and King takes
has indeed the critic aligned yeah
Knight takes 96 as I said was good but
King takes is the problem so knight c6
and here you just have no way to save
yourself yeah if you would have one or
two Tempe like a night or night already
here and so and then okay it doesn't
work um so and that was this line Knight
h4 I concluded would be okay after
Bishop g5 but the computer even get says
f4 is great okay that didn't make sense
this and now you got multiple problems
okay so that doesn't even work um yeah
and here I couldn't quite make it work I
thought this was still somewhat
interesting because Bishop age 694 is
okay that's kind of true but the problem
is that he has still a five works which
I didn't look at but I was kind of
desperate at this moment I didn't I
didn't quite felt I was on the right
track yeah this is indeed bad it's the
same kind of thing as before you can
take with the barn
Oh here even whoop t7 is strong Wow
ouch
everything is hanging so jam what can we
take from this I saw some ideas
correctly but I didn't really solve this
position in a in a really conclusive way
now let's do a second one that took a
long time
position number 18 let's see if I know
this one or not
and
you
no don't know the position that's good
so the game alien off against Yun Smits
you're bought whites perspective
looks a little bit almost an opening
position
definitely something on move for know
twelve or fourteen something like that
interesting
yeah but what I basically always say the
opening yourself to make many strategic
decisions
and there's really not much of a
difference they are to a middle name
some people after sir yeah they say okay
this is just the opening I don't look at
openings but oftentimes they just have
complex strategic decisions and needs to
be viewed as just just a normal
decision-making process what you're what
you're doing okay is that right I think
it is why to move why to move
I think it's right
and really often screw up
the head of the
pieces
okay and I have to switch off the engine
no I have to enter it again
[Laughter]
I came let's see if I'm a bit quicker
this time now after I have set it up
once I should be a bit quicker
it a8 mean
night
yeah he knows
like king I guess
and if I pawned sorry for this long wait
but you can check the position out a
little bit while I'm brewing the sub ad
to switch off the engine ed would be be
awfully would immediately give me in
hint now so this is why to play le on
off against mates probably a good thing
again now what is going on in this
position black probably has just played
the move e5 to free himself
hmm we have a
position when White has got the bishop
pair and he would definitely like to
open up the position in his terms
a way to not do it is so take only five
this is really clear that something like
this leads nowhere blacken probably just
snap this off and is fine so the capture
is not really great often a good
solution in such a scenario is to play
the move d5 because white is arguing
that and I don't think this is best I'm
just showing the idea is that if you get
something like that that this Bishop
here is strong this would be the case if
we would have a four in and be much more
developed then the bishop on g7 looks a
bit stupid but here this doesn't seem to
work at all because black has at least
the move Knight b6 and this is already a
bit awkward yeah we don't want to trade
everything off there and an additional
problem might be the movie form that is
also sometimes tricky
at night be six alone is kind of enough
to persuade me
not check this
but if we
just a little bit
you
yeah one problem is if we just look at
this like everything gets traded win
takes is just never anything yeah I mean
just two
illustrate Queen takes Queen takes rook
takes rook the eight and I mean black is
better Herod stupid
and rook takes there is Queenie one
showing that our development is pretty
bad so the move d5 does not work
what are we going to do we cannot move
the deep on as the conclusion at least
it doesn't lead to anything
I think
a more or less normal would be to move
the Queen in this position get it out of
the night be six plan
but okay this is a very
simplistic approach like what looks
normal
can check other ideas before can be
played to attack the Queen not sure that
black is bothered all that much
it's better than the five
still not very good
you
now the move that comes to mind is
Bishop d2 that prepares v5 in some way
going form discovered ideas
difficult
you
what is what is I don't really as the
think I understand the position
correctly
besides going D 5vm the only thing I see
for Wyatt as a plan is before b5 really
don't really see much else
you
I don't think you can do much with peace
play in such a situation you probably
have to change the pawn structure
somewhat
you
my best bet at the moon would be really
to go before in this position hmm not
really convinced
I'd say Queen c7
you
still feels like very solid from like
if I've still not leading to anything
besides the fact that after before the
movie freud's also getting much more
interesting now that the diagonal is
opened
mmm doesn't feel right
of course I can play something normal IB
should be too awesome
don't really believe that
position like that is all that exciting
and maybe I have a slight advantage here
not about this but it could be slightly
better for white and it's nothing
special and it doesn't feel like a
solution to a problem
we'll be three is a reasonable
prophylactic move that's also pretty
clear because I think something like
this is not
in any way problematic in terms of
weakness of the IQ PM you know I'm
really active here so that doesn't
really scare me but it also doesn't feel
like anything special
[Music]
you
and exercises from the grandmaster
preparation books are really difficult
I usually get the strategic ones right
have to say but I'm struggling the one
before and this one is really not coming
to me easily
you
hmm what am I missing
you
one line that is important is though
this one yeah I had 96 maybe he can take
immediately
this could be could be better
better choice
okay but not be
antigone deform salat great
hmm I feel I'm not getting it I just
don't get something that's going on in
this position
me black fields very solidly I don't see
much going on
I'm also not seeing that there is a
Oh threat
going on maybe maybe the main point of
this exercise is to recognize that d5 is
bad because it is the normal move
strategically speaking it's a normal
move
but as we have looked or it doesn't work
a Bishop d2 of just looking at the queen
bed oops
looking at the Queen but after it takes
I don't see anything great
ninety-five
it takes with a pawn
you
and this is definitely nothing special
as always
move like that and then I mean
that cannot be great
we knew a problem
or somewhere here
Wi-Fi air for not so bad
maybe night b6 is not a good timing
[Music]
I'm currently not really threatening d5
because of 95 so maybe maybe black
should do something else
boo-ki eight or something hmm again I
feel I'm not really getting it I think
if you give me if we now say make a move
I would probably play this but not with
any sort of
ticular enthusiasm like yes I found
something good
really not hmm okay
in close position number 18 let's see
what I miss him
[Music]
you
No and so it is be form means I wasn't
completely off but here not Bishop b2
but b5 is the move yeah this is I've
thought about it but quite believe it
it's so great
mooom
you
Hadassah Benham should be it's much more
active this happened in the game Knight
b6 Queen b3
and thus yeah this is difficult that is
diffic called
you
you know now this is fine of course I'm
the point is not weak at all and you
have this constant pressure the c-pawn
can never really move and yeah that's
awkward so I got it like half riot yeah
so this be before I key move was correct
but you cannot really say I solve this
one okay let's do a final one
number 115
[Music]
Leko grease shock
so
at
I don't have the engine on it all right
yes okay white souffle I guess
yeah
wait to play position to me
you
yeah this position probably
[Music]
is from some sort of anti martial or
some
I'm quieter
we'll pass
oh is that right
but this
you know and it's wise to move wide to
play
yeah
code
we have equal material again
you
some some imbalances of course black has
this poor information
and sometimes be vulnerable in
particular six can be vulnerable
you
because to really put
lots of pressure on that
you
yeah I'm just looking at this a little
bit and try to
it feel for what's going on
pieces are well positioned and
pieces are not well positioned
my mind the nights here on g3 would feel
better on see forward this is quite a
long journey
like this
it makes some sense not completely
nonsensical now the move that always has
to be checked of courses c5 the central
on break
you like
it's netting much at the moment if we
look at the five night takes
on Teague's
we have a clever move here no probably
not
yeah you definitely have some
compensation for the porn without any
question but
um
also doesn't look like
particularly special
[Music]
you
yeah I wonder I wonder what black is
trying to do this black have anything
good here
maybe Knight to g4 can be an idea trying
to go to e5
would be an idea this also
maybe d5
after which we would like to probably
play e5 and then hmm
Neji for is not quite working I guess
after age 3
I'm just thinking what would happen if
black is to move to trying to figure out
if I can do something against it or if
there is anything that is really a huge
concern because this is often the way to
figure out a good prophylactic move you
just think okay black to move what would
he do
Aoife the five I might also just take
on takes pawn takes Knight f5 something
like that
it could be a problem also it takes
takes Knight g5 can be a problem
yeah that also looks a bit awkward
so the Knights are probably well
positioned to answer d5
you're not irritated by the background
noise somebody's and doing I'm not sure
what exactly what they're doing
something outside of my apartment dorm
and sporting something I don't know what
it is
[Music]
you
I would really consider to play h3 here
it looks like a very useful move in many
ways but it also doesn't feel like this
is a solution to this problem
[Music]
you
I don't see much that I can do with the
bishop here and that that really is
difficult to see where the bishop could
go
[Music]
it wouldn't be bad on the long diagonal
here let's say if we would have c4
played Bishop one c3 this would be
better than being on c1 but I don't
quite see how how to get them
you
look b1
and they would be six
and it tooks kind of reasonable
don't like
the pawn is unprotected in that case not
that there is a direct line
it could be problematic in some
Technicolor proceedings when the
position opens up that this is hanging
I think like h3 but
it doesn't feel right it doesn't feel
like I'm
standing what's going on at all
you
but do we display completely differently
against the defy of IDM
[Music]
if this is an idea at all I'm actually
not convinced that it is
I feel if I go here let's say
my curly
move and focus that this should be good
for white this should be good
the first line that should be good and
even better looks this I guess because
it takes I feel that this must be good
for white I have 95 potentially but
looking at here 96 and also this one and
they both look pretty pretty weird for
black
so I don't think he's really threatening
to change the pawn structure that much
and we prevented the 94 idea
you
each three maybe rupee one
but what I was retained about is this
move early then it felt a little bit
now I cannot go if five
and in this I feel
it's probably good in this particular
case there is one of one line where this
is hanging actually
and I guess h3 but as you see and feel
I'm not really in any way confident
about this so let's have a look I don't
want you create a three-hour video here
just reach him I mean if you really do
this as an exercise yourself you should
probably look a little bit deeper
and try to really figure it out
now h3 is correct so I wasn't I was
right
[Music]
I just read out what's in the book why
should be a little better on account of
the freer play and the pressure along
the D file the safest way to secure its
edges by taking into account blacks
intentions at this point the bishop on
e7 is not very well placed and then I
don't have six also somewhat restricted
therefore his most natural planets
Knight g4 Bishop f6 95 Niko Niko
prevents this with the simple move h3 so
ok I got one right it just sometimes in
those exercises you have a hard time to
figure out if you really hit hit the
nail on the head is that really the
right move h3 is some very slowish
whatever yeah it's a it's not a yam BAM
move I think yes this is right like you
figure out an exchange sacrifice or
something like that but it really makes
sense it restricts black even more and
white is probably a little bit better
long term in the game Queen c7 was paper
gree shock
and now 95 was played Bishop g5 is also
better for while yeah it's it's it's
really a little bit and it's
unconvenient inconvenient inconvenience
right like the movie
ninety-five
it would address the game
and white was better and one on more
sixty and ultimately so I got one right
this is a purely prophylactic exercise
if you look for high class exercises the
Grandmaster preparation books are very
good but as you saw it's not easy yeah I
mean I'm fairly normal-sized
international master and usually quite
good in strategy and I'm I really have
to work hard to find out some of the
solutions so um don't be frustrated if
you get get one of those books and
you're you're stuck it's pretty normal
yeah it's it's really difficult
okay guys hope you enjoyed this
discussing three positions in depth and
I'll be back tomorrow probably with the
end of this video thanks a lot for
watching